it took courage for marina obsi anakova
to protest vladimir putin's invasion of
ukraine storming the set of one of
russia's most popular news programs with
a poster reading in russian stop the war
don't believe the propaganda they are
lying to you here the moment spread
quickly around the world the risk of
going to prison or worse is very real in
a country that just legislated even
tighter restrictions on journalists and
freedom of expression there could be
retaliation against your family this is
a regime the vladimir putin regime
that has not hesitated to use the
harshest possible measures against
dissent
family members and supporters feared the
worst after obsi anakova disappeared
into police custody for nearly 24 hours
with the kremlin calling her actions
hooliganism she says police interrogated
her extensively for 14 hours and she
wasn't allowed a lawyer or to contact
her family she's been fined not for the
on-air protest but for a separate video
statement urging others to protest
wearing a necklace with the colors of
the ukraine flag her father's home
country she's not backing down it wasn't
my own
decision
yeah if i made this decision by myself
because i
don't like
russia starts this
invasion what's happening in ukraine is
a crime she says and russia is the
aggressor ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky has singled out austriana kova
who also has two children for praise
since she spoke out a growing number of
prominent journalists have reportedly
left their positions at russian state
media including lilia gildieva a leading
tv anchor who'd been praised by putin
gildieva has fled russia the bravery of
these people is absolutely extraordinary
because they don't know it would have
the effect that they hope for
but they act out of principle he says
they could be seen as heroes if the
russian invasion fails or forgotten if
putin succeeds
ross lord global news